PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Welcome to "Get
Cooking in Cloud," where
we share the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen.
I am Priyanka, and we
have a very special guest.
CARTER MORGAN:
I'm Carter Morgan.
In this episode, we'll
be making a souffle.
[CHUCKLING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
that is a great metaphor
because souffles have a
reputation of being complex
but are actually very
simple to prepare, just
like the theme of today's
show, migrating monoliths
to microservices-based
cloud applications.
CARTER MORGAN: We're not
actually making a souffle?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Uh-uh.
No.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]
Imagine you're an
IT professional
in charge of a complex
website you need to modernize.
Imagine it's designed as
a monolith and it's time
to move to the cloud.
Maybe the way things have been
done is mostly working for you,
but when it comes time
to upgrade a service
or add a new feature, you
start running into problems,
like feature rollouts
taking forever
because your
monolithic app can only
be deployed once a quarter.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, without a recipe,
it can be hard to know
exactly how to transition
your application in a way
that minimizes risk, downtime,
and customer dissatisfaction
and also money lost.
While modernizing your
platform by moving to the cloud
and by switching
to microservices
involves learning new tools
and new ways of working,
all of that can
seem overwhelming.
CARTER MORGAN: But those
fears shouldn't stop you
from reaping the benefits of
a microservice-based cloud
platform.
You want to modernize
your platform
to provide a more nimble
and scalable environment
for the individual
features of the site,
where the features can
be more easily managed
and updated than if they're
part of the monolithic platform.
Running in such an environment
leads to faster improvements.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, if you want
to just migrate everything
at once, that would
be a lot of risk involved.
But if you were to just
migrate feature by feature,
you can avoid that
large amount of risk.
CARTER MORGAN: There are three
main patterns for this type
of migration to the cloud--
lift and shift, improve and
move, and rip and replace.
We're going to use a
specific flavor of the rip
and replace pattern, where
the pattern is applied
incrementally to each
feature of the application
rather than to the
application as a whole.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Ooh, microservings.
Over the next few videos, we
will use e-commerce website
as an example because--
CARTER MORGAN:
Veggies aren't fun.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: No,
Carter, because many of these
are built with monolithic
proprietary tools
so they are really good
candidates for this migration.
But even if you don't
have an e-commerce site,
you can apply the principles
that we will cover here
to a wide range of workloads.
CARTER MORGAN: In addition
to this migration pattern,
we'll show you two
hybrid patterns.
During the migration
itself, the application
has a hybrid architecture
where some of the features
are in the cloud and some
are still on premises.
After the migration is finished,
the complete cloud application
is hosted in the
cloud, but it still
interacts with backend services
that remain on premises.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Wow, moving
to cloud could be messy.
Well, there you have it.
If you're looking to migrate
your existing monolithic
platform to the
cloud, you've gotten
a taste of what's in store
for the rest of the series.
Stay tuned for
the next episode--
CARTER MORGAN: Where we will
actually make a souffle.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: No.
CARTER MORGAN: Where we will
walk through the migration
process.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
But if you are
excited to get on this
migration journey with us,
then don't forget to like
and subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]